i feel like i'm being old because it's
like i'm cold and then i'm warm and then
i'm cold i'm going to go outside and
it's going to be
uh
temperate because i'm not telling you
where i am
um
because we're recording either gonna be
greenway audio it's either gonna be you
know
bright shiny yes shiny tropics or the
pole or maybe oceana you're on a boat
that's very very stable right now
you're working with tom cruise on that
on that movie that's being shown in
space right you're actually on the space
station right now this is yeah
we're in space
i can fly
all things are possible it's shiny yeah
it's always shiny in philadelphia have
you been listening to their podcast far
be it for me to promote another podcast
you've been listening to their the the
girls so the guys who do um the guys who
wrote uh who write always sunny they
have a podcast it's really good it's one
of those ones where they do you know an
episode a week or whatever but like just
genuinely really remember those better
than this obviously if anyone's
listening to this i want something to be
more insane that's better
do you shout out to our competition
that is beating us yeah oh they are this
is the thing about the internet there is
there is no competition on the internet
you can watch all of it
you're not up against a time slot yeah
it's distracting i was watching somebody
described the difference between twitch
streams versus youtubers and how
youtubers trying to sort of like all the
drama that can happen with like youtuber
culture of different sort of seemingly
competitive
uh channels sort of trying to do uh like
dmcas on each other when they do
response videos and stuff and they were
saying it doesn't make sense to have
that um
on youtube because it's so not very near
it's it is not zero sum at all given the
fact that it it is an on-demand platform
whereas twitch
sort of makes more sense for people to
be a bit more competitive with each
other since it's live and therefore if
you're watching me right now it's at the
expense of somebody else because you
don't tend to watch twitch
uh after the fact and i thought that was
an interesting
way to differentiate between the
cultures of you know people that live on
twitch versus those that live on youtube
and why there is a bit more of a culture
of supportiveness amongst youtubers
anyway apropos of nothing but i thought
it was it was interesting right you know
i
i don't know man i kind of disagree
because
the the thing that twitch gives you is a
raid right so
there's a really great way for people to
support other twitch streamers and go
hey everybody go raid this channel or
we're going to dump all of our followers
um into this other room so i think that
twitch is way is what you're saying is
that twitch is more supportive or that
youtube was more supportive saying that
like from one
from one personality or you know content
creator as it were to another
youtube it's easier to be supportive of
one another
given that in real time like there's
nothing stopping you from watching two
channels religiously whereas if two
streamers are
are playing simultaneously
uh you have to pick one uh and so they
are gonna naturally tend to be a more
territorial
um and but but you're right i mean some
of the most fun
times i've ever i've ever had is like
doing streams with deck arts where
they'll find a channel that's a fraction
of their size and and rate it and the
person is like completely blown away
uh
to see like hundreds of people just
suddenly stream in unexpectedly to their
kind of intimate corner of the internet
that is to me a really really cool
feature that i i really enjoy uh every
time yeah and it's also it's
non-performative
you know what i mean it's not
doing something for the benefit of
showing others that you're being you
know
look guys
i'm very lonely right now
i've missed i missed these weeks off um
i yeah i'm about to head back into the
fray it's going to be a lot of fun but
i've i've had um
a great uh several days off and
um i i don't know if this is relevant
anymore i feel like i'm always
a little bit behind the curve on some
stuff
um i
this might be a might bethel episode
i'm ready they're my favorite they're my
friends they're the ones i watch always
i will
that guy's got some really good points
there's a smart fella right there yeah
that's cool
i i feel like uh in order to to be a
relevant person
and to try to maintain some relevance to
culture i have to be where the
conversation is and the conversation for
better or for worse is in social media
so you can say what you want to about
social media i certainly have my
take on it but the reality is is that if
you want to know
what the word on the street is that's
the street and so there are the words
um
and it doesn't mean i necessarily have
to engage with it it doesn't mean i have
to even have an opinion on it but it's
incontrovertibly true that that is where
the conversation is so given that as a
premise
i was really surprised with the nintendo
direct look at that left turn that was
solid um
i'm on topic a little bit
i i was looking and saying i'm just
curious mike i know you always says like
any feedback is is solid feedback
but the two like the the most consistent
thing that i was seeing sometimes both
or one of the two
was if nintendo doesn't announce mario
kart 9 or breath of the wild 2
they go [ __ ] themselves it was just it
was it was just like there's nothing
else that we want to see
but there was only two
i love mario kart like i got my switch
here and i am i'm like plowing through
the mirror missions right now and it's
it's super fun it's something that it's
something that is challenging for me or
traveler can literally play and i i that
is a that is a great game right
broad base yeah
breath of the wild is something that
we've talked to our friend andrea pacino
before and who here's someone who is a
literal genius and has been in games for
three decades
and that to him is like his his absolute
favorite game of all time ever been made
of the art form
yeah so i understand people being super
stoked about that but what i don't
understand is
a
why do you think that is the cultural
response
and b do you think publishers
sub question developers
care
i've i've certainly been like i i like
one of the things that always happens
whenever we announce anything or do
anything that kind of we get any kind of
platform support so like we'll do a i
don't know i'll write a blog post on the
playstation blog or something there will
always be fifty percent of the responses
to like my thought through kind of
announcement of something i've worked
years on will be
yeah but when's this game out or what's
the it's got a little it's a little it
stings a little for sure but like
i don't know i think i think honestly i
think the nintendo direct model also
kind of relies on that right because it
kind of relies on an audience
watching who are waiting for that big
announcement of that thing they want
it's kind of pooling the idea being that
like if you're into one thing nintendo
does you're gonna watch every nintendo
direct and that's gonna give avenues for
them to talk to you about every other
thing that's important to them so it's
definitely i think it's i think it's
isn't it kind of the plan isn't that
kind of it working as designs to an
except like obviously abuse sucks and
people should be polite but like in
terms of like specifically
is it a problem that people are that
fixated on a specific game i think
that's what nintendo's doing i think
nintendo's making the bet that if they
put out a news story or if they put out
a video of the new zelda
they'd get all the people there who
won't see it but if they do it all under
one roof they get to tell those same
players about
you know the advance wars re-release or
this cool new indie game that they're
throwing some support behind you know so
i think it's it's working as planned i
think that's kind of a i assume that's
the logic behind it
also what do you think
i don't really accept the
well
also doesn't except where are you going
to accept the premise austin's like i'm
not sure culture does happen on social
media troy
actually
as we've uh noted here the actual user
base of twitter
and then the subset of that of people
who actually tweet the most represent a
vanishingly tiny percent of the overall
population so it's an interesting thing
where
it but on twitter though i am broadly
speaking about social media though
because that's going to include reddit
that's going to include instagram that's
going to include online conversations
with the
thing i keep hearing about from the
young people in my life well and
facebook is the real is the real true
like there you're talking about billions
of users i mean that it's like okay that
really is probably the this is it's meta
it's metadata
you look embarrassingly out of touch
austin there i'm sorry like it's not i
apologize for using it's a very current
show i actually still call it
facebook.com thank you very much
uh
i missed my little live stream
in the corner
do you see the cycle in this stuff
i've been trying to get a hold of the
myspace customer service no one's
answering
where is tom
i loved the uh onion headline
the 12 people in the audience who got
that joke will have old enough to have
yeah
i i was friends with tom i kept him on
there with his little
uh but uh i uh yep yep
but i remember there was a great there
was a great uh onion headline that was
like arc like digital archaeologists
have found a lost civilization on
myspace where they were like no one
knows what happened where it appeared to
be a thriving uh civilization and then
one day complete abandonment and it was
a hilarious anyway all that said i think
that it's interesting where
responses i guess i was really
specifically talking about twitter in
terms of it's really not representative
of the it is a far more self-selected
group
but
that doesn't
this is where i was mixed because it
they do they do actually take the
temperature
of
culture from twitter
um and it does have downstream effects
whether or not it is a representative
sample of the overall user base or not
but that's where you can have games that
are it's kind of like the difference
between rotten tomatoes user scores
versus critic scores where sometimes
there can be a thing that's absolutely
piled on by critics but meanwhile gets
great numbers and gets great sales and
whatnot because the average consumer or
the target audience for it is just way
out of step with whatever the critics
are looking for and the flip has also
happened plenty of times where you see
movies with like 100 critic rating that
are absolute bombs
uh because the audience just doesn't
give a [ __ ]
um and so yeah i that's where i i found
myself going well
you know i don't know that it i've never
understood why they care as much as they
do about like the twitter response to a
thing when you can have something get
all riled up on twitter and meanwhile
still sell millions of units because the
average person who's
playing it doesn't care but but it's it
is more complicated i don't think they
did care
i don't think they did care i think they
they 100 based upon obviously what they
put out they had to have known that
people were going to be up in
arms leading up to it and even before
they announced a nintendo direct is
going to be on this date and that was
you know several days before and
immediately the the you know well this
is also where
as far as like our internet filter our
like information
filtration is also a problem because
all see some things start trending
amongst those that i follow
where it's like oh
everyone is saying this when in reality
it's i never look at that
but even the way that it filters the
trending is sort of algorithmically
specific to you
um so it's still going to be a
reflection of
where my corner of the internet resides
and then you'll see that
i'll pick it up and go for twitter now
because then i'll see things where the
media go well people on twitter are
saying this and it'll be quoting like a
few random accounts
that are
you know well that's just hack that's
just that's just hack journalism but you
see that that's like the default
position like for this is i guess just
me showing my general disdain for the
media but i i uh but i do this show has
a completely different time bro without
allah
it's true i mean how many times do you
see things where it's presented as if
this is the prevailing narrative and
there is their evidence of that is
here's three random twitter you see that
everybody does that all all ideologies
all that that's not i'm not i'm
i think yeah i think lazy people of all
ideologies do that for sure especially
because we live in a time where they
need to have that article ready by noon
and it's 11 30. so they will just grab a
whatever twitter satisfies the
the the demands of the article being
written whatever account whatever tweet
specifically regardless of of anything i
i don't even think it's by noon i don't
think it's so much of like hey we're
going to press at this date it is
most people
will only will read the most current
article doesn't matter the source
so if the guardian puts up something and
it's topical and it says 38 minutes ago
people are going to read that versus
something that is
washington post or new york times that
was three hours ago i want the most
recent
news
so
the most recent is the last word is the
only word that people are
are seeing but i i don't think that
nintendo really did care they're like
this is what we're coming out with
like i said i think it's the intention i
think the more you're talking and the
stronger your opinions are about
nintendo
while they're trying to promote stuff
because everyone who sees any kind of
talk about it is going to watch it i
think it's i think it all i think the
best news is that fuels the machine you
know
yeah and the best news that came out of
that is like we have switches in stock
and that was the main thing i think that
people didn't even realize that they
wanted was to know that they could
actually buy them i also think that
because that's the number one problem
i think that nintendo's also
kind of always
just done what nintendo's gonna do
regardless i feel like that's sort of
their mo just going back decades now
where there's always like nintendo
if nintendo had felt market pressure to
to do what they think the public wants
we would have seen you know a move
of games more like what you expect on
sony and xbox and steam and like but
nintendo's always been pretty
like
a sure of themselves in their identity
yeah yeah to their to their i remember
like i say that positively like oh yeah
sure
it's part of what makes nintendo as a
word means something other than just a
platform it's there's a brand there's
there's flavor and texture so there's
even musical implications for what that
you read um did you read oscar water
did you read that it's a book it's
really good what is this
it's so it's it's not a book is this so
called book
books it's like this thing we used to do
it's very much the twitter of its day um
but no oh you mean the audible stuff
yeah it's like audible it's like an
audible but they they write a skirmish
paper yeah ask a water iwa
actually the ceo of nintendo yes
oscar
that's what i heard too i heard oscar
water and i was like is that what they
serve at the ceremony it's like very
expensive
oscar water
are you saying oscar why do you talk
weird feller it is weird it's one thing
like
yeah yeah it's really good
it's worth a watch
[Applause]
more focus on his philosophy than you'd
expect going in like it's about yeah
dude i'm into it kind of gives you a
really real insight into exactly what
you're talking about in that kind of
nintendo mindset
um futuristic uh sorry go ahead troy
i was gonna say i'm a terrible futurist
because there have been twice
when i've looked at nintendo and like
they're probably you know what they
should what they probably should do get
out of the hardware business
license all of the games just like
everybody else felt like they've jumped
the shark
completely it was like how did you do so
good with the wii and get it so wrong
with the wii u
and then when the switch came out i was
like you still don't got it oh or is it
going to be the number one platform oh
yeah not only because of accessibility
you were skeptical of the switch when
you saw the switch oh yeah totally
skeptical of the switch nobody wants to
do that
uh well maybe because i didn't really
get it ready to run up on the roof and
because that was the the initial trailer
wasn't it was people on the roof playing
with yeah yeah
it's most consoles nobody wants to hold
these little things
most consoles have like a good one a bad
one a good one and you can you can map
that or you can map that to certain
bosses within the industry moving
between companies but you can also map
it to like you know arrogance or having
control of the marketplace like you you
can see like
definitely not going to name and shame
but like you can definitely see consoles
where it's been a good one and a bad one
and a good one and a bad one like these
people learned from the mistakes of the
lord
people love that but that's a terrible
console
it anywhere gameplay
take it anywhere that you could plug in
and have a tv attached to see with that
handle you can see the kind of the roots
you can see them starting to think about
that console as a social object and kind
of taking it with you and you can see
those for sure was the gamecube actually
terrible or was it just that the 64 was
so good that everything
64 was so great even though it had the
worst controller ever somebody was just
like [ __ ] it put it all in there it was
at a joystick and buttons and triggers
and two three handles it was it was the
weirdest controller the least ergonomic
controller i definitely never understood
the middle prong the like trident model
but if you want to hold it like this i
just can't recall ever doing it like
this yeah but it didn't the gamecube was
a good console like the gamecube i mean
it what i mean it was actually playing a
ton of games eventually like the wii is
basically a gamecube in a different
shape box so like you know it's it was
effectively
i mean
there's some changes i remember the
controllers for the gamecube being that
no i'm saying the hardware a lot of the
hardware in the wii is the gamecube like
it's a it's a souped up well that was
the next iteration of it wasn't it
did it go gamecube did we it was
gameplay
versus say the difference between ps4
and five where the five is just a
considerably more powerful piece yeah i
mean i i've got i can't
on a hardware level very very similar on
the in terms of what's inside the box
obviously the innovation comes with the
controller and all of that but
right
for sure but that's that's what's so
funny is that it had nothing to do with
really the heart i mean i'm sure there's
a lot of hardware and processing power
that goes into being able to have those
controllers do that but had nothing to
do with like what do we do with the con
the console
their focus shifted to the controller
and that is what unlocked everything
that is what got grandmothers to play
that's what got people the whole
mentality was get people off the couch
and i think everybody else was saying
how do we keep them on the couch how do
we keep them playing and this was oh we
don't we that's
they're smart man these guys know what
they're talking about and it's it's i i
i've been watching a lot of i talked to
you about this last time mike i've been
watching a lot of poker and i'm now
going through the 2005 world series and
it's just so crazy to watch this random
change and somebody actually corrected
me in the comments and thank you i said
that 2003 uh the whole reason why the
poker boom happened was because i'm
sorry i don't remember your your uh i
read that comment i know exactly the
comments great comment they were like
you're partly right with your
historicity of
yeah i was like
thank you so much for that it was it was
not only there was a it was a really
critical component to and this actually
ties in so give me a second there was a
critical component to not only the 2003
world series being won by a internet
player chris moneymaker
but it was also the fact that espn
picked it up
on their main channel i believe and they
put cameras in the in the feature table
and they started doing a feature table
thing so you could actually see where in
the whole cars and all of a sudden
instantly drama happened
and the audience was able to engage with
the sport that
whereas before it was a purely
observational thing was it what was your
mistake was it leaving off the espn part
or what was the espn and and the whole
card camera the so being able to see
that it's like that's really what did it
was all of a sudden there was there was
now something for the audience to watch
versus these people just playing and you
turn it over and that's when the drama
happens like i don't want to make it to
that part so that's a really good point
to add in
to to that end it's it's exactly what
nintendo's doing where you can see this
huge evolutionary jump
should i let in alana or do we want to
talk about pogba for the rest of today
no we'll talk about pokemon
and go we're talking about poker on
youtube we should prank her we need to
work out uh yeah
that will be enough for prank it's just
i feel like i should have pushed it so
that's that's really why i i feel like
my time has come and it's it's probably
best
you've had me run for what it's like i
salute you to hang up to hang up the mic
i don't feel like um you know or or the
suit as it were i don't need to
do any of those she's thoroughly
distracted um yeah yeah there's that
i'm also no audio she's fighting at the
moment it doesn't matter but man that
boom i hear you were you quitting
no it's breaking you
i intend to
but i'm trying to make sure that that
would be a responsible thing for me to
do first because she might need more
humans and a larger home and a backyard
um but she's also pretty in love with me
so it'll be tough
you can find a park somewhere around you
lit where you live
yeah it's also like a time thing i just
spend so much time in a pc all day that
she mostly seems to be fine but she's
going crazy right now because she needs
to go for a walk
uh which yeah at least she knows how to
tell me that um so what was the prank
i'm so sorry do you want to start again
hang on
if you look
no matter how high you get the curvature
of the earth you can never see it you
can never see there's no evidence
i'll believe it with my own eyes
right it doesn't matter because that's
why the earth is paler hey i visited the
ice wall
you visited the ice wall yeah i got
turned away by the fbi
don't they say that there are um
penguins
guarding it that the penguins there are
aggressive i think it's a thing yes
please tell me this they're like
government-engineered
penguins like super penguins
i made one flat earther youtube video
once
to be clear my stance was that it's
nonsense and so i still get comments
from them all hey
she just stole a coffee cup out of my
bin you can't do that my uh watch me
okay
my i totally get flat earthers man i
have a friend that uh when he graduated
from school
he's a composer and he and he was going
to move to la he was going to school in
boston and he he said
you know before i moved to la i want to
do one last sort of wild adventure since
theoretically that won't be possible
moving forward so he he and his friends
rented like a decommissioned or they
bought like an old decommissioned school
bus
and they drove it from boston to
antarctica over a six-month period
and
they literally
they literally got well you go all the
way to the southern tip of argentina and
then you get on a boat uh for four days
right it's or two days at sea the
drake's passes it's a couple of yeah i
think it's it's a whole under i mean
this took them half a year the whole the
whole thing and there was only one part
of it where they theoretically cheated
there was like one
narrow segment of like panama which was
just overtly controlled by drug cartels
where they had to put the bus on a boat
and basically go out into the pacific
ocean and go around and reconnect with
the land like in
you know
so then friend called like jeremy
clarkson is this this feels like one of
their episodes it was it was crazy
the funny thing was that relevant to
what you were just talking about the
funny thing is that he told me the
biggest takeaway he had from arriving in
antarctica was the overwhelming smell of
bird [ __ ] he was like yeah it's he was
like it's just it's sort of a static
environment
and so
to be quick you can just arrive there
yeah yeah that i think they've changed
it to where you have to be a part of a
science research vessel like you can't
but i don't think you could stay i think
it was like it's kind of like you'll
have a school bus maybe they presented
it with the school the school bus was
abandoned in argentina at that point but
they all went with the cartel yeah they
basically
no that was it that was more happens
that was we you need to be playing world
worldly uh that makes you guess
countries based on their shape uh
they i gave that a try and i gave moodle
a try and i was like [ __ ] either of
these i can't did you know that little
was made by gary witta
yes shut your mouth yeah i think that i
found it because he kept tweeting about
it yeah it's just he won't show oh
that's crazy i thought it talked
independently i heard about it
independently and then i saw him
tweeting i was like wow he's such a fan
of loot and then at some point i
realized holy [ __ ] that's his thing
that's so funny
well he's gary
sat and typed in a bunch of rude words
into a spreadsheet at some point
words yeah
the problem is somebody told me about
that the video and said it was like
there's like 12 that again in my mind i
was like
child
yeah no i'm not getting it
i did get my word today on the second
guess though which never happens it's my
first second guess it's a huge one
this is all about flexes today isn't it
is it yeah believe it or not
alana marie aloysius pierce the third
i used to say my full name
i know i love
when she got baptized they almost
drowned her it was just like oh that's
jesus
one more
uh
there you go
and that's how i ended up like this
avoid satan um i was talking about
nintendo direct
i love that yay you're on top of it
yeah yeah and i was just talking about
how hilariously you
that was a dog we can bring it back you
can bring it back what were we talking
about
i was saying how i was i was surprised
not surprised uh but the the general
conversation that at least i was seeing
which could have been different from
anybody else was that
if nintendo wasn't going to talk about
or they weren't going to announce a
release date it wasn't just like we're
working on it was like we want to know a
release date
of uh mario kart 9 and or
breath of the wild 2 they didn't want
anything to do with a nintendo direct
and i was just curious
uh what your thoughts were especially
now being a part of a dev if if you guys
you know if you feel that
hey in anticipation of psx or whatever
it is now or e3 or comic con or any of
these big tentpole four wall whether it
be something that you like nintendo does
on their own or sony does on their own
um something that's a part more of like
gamescom or whatever where it's more of
an international event it's like people
are going to be expecting us to show
this
um if if you agree with that pressure or
if you feel like it's a truly indicative
of a culture or whatever i think if
anybody ever expects anything from a
nintendo direct
they're nuts i feel like you should
never go into a nintendo direct and
expect anything
not no i don't mean that in a negative
way uh it's just that they just really
every time i can't predict what's going
to be in them and i'm like oh my god i
didn't expect this i think that you're
setting yourself up to fail um
i feel like it's probably certainly
difficult for the marketing teams you
have to deal with that kind of thing to
figure out like we know that that this
expectation exists how do we cater to
that like i wonder how often they do
cater to pressure
in my head like being part of a team
if
they were to show something from santa
monica studio
i think it's it's like it'd be exciting
for me if i was seeing people like
really hardly anticipating it and then
getting to watch their reactions to it
but i don't feel like like i would ever
feel like we would need to because
people want to see more stuff i don't
i don't have to think about that
thankfully but nintendo directs are
never what i expect i thought this one
was great though um i was not expecting
breath of the wild to be shocked if that
comes out this year i think like we've
seen nothing and especially considering
the history of how many zelda games have
been delayed it's not like a safe bet by
any means
um but that was the other one oh mario
if it launches mario kart nine dude look
at this
it's all about advanced wars guys come
on that was the big one i do know a lot
of advanced was fans yeah i'm surprised
it feels like they're backpedaling on
the whole assassin's creed thing because
that's dropping this week
and i just i'm seeing nothing for it so
it makes me feel like it's
yeah i feel like it's another potential
i'm not trying to disparage it at all
but i'm wondering if it's a little bit
more like the gta port where it's like
you don't want to play it on the switch
i think part of the thing with the ezio
collection is that um
it's very hard to go back and play which
is unfortunate because i loved those
games but if you try and play them now
because assassin's creed
has
so much it's evolved so much but also
influenced so many other games like
especially the climbing
um that i think now going back to play
the ezio collection is actually
difficult i think you'd be fine if
you've never played an assassin's creed
and you go straight to the ezio
collection you're gonna have a great
time i think the the fantasy okay then
as someone who loves gta 5
would you go back and play the
the
anthology of the collection that they
did did you go back and do it did you go
back and play vice city and
so we actually just got a comment
yesterday where somebody was like well
this age poorly because apparently there
was like one of our first maybe 20
episodes
where i said how awesome it would be if
they uh remastered gta vice city
i was like i just want by city when they
do it'll be excellent and i didn't play
it will be excellent because uh i saw a
bunch of videos showing the performance
so my logic was i'll wait a bit and hope
that it gets a little bit better um
because i would love to because i think
i had mentioned it on that episode that
i couldn't finish that game because i
got a game breaking bug so i played like
maybe 10 hours and then had to stop so
i'd love to go back to bi city but yeah
i i think the original you couldn't
finish yeah it brought oh my god yeah i
had the dja
trilogy collection this little box set
and i played the others but i couldn't
play by city so
i'd love that but no i i mean
i don't feel like i feel like gta is old
enough that the idea that it's aged
poorly even as somebody who's played i
don't know
500 hours of gta 5
doesn't hurt me oh that's my my doorbell
someone's at the door someone's at the
door
i'm it's fine um i'm never not elected
by your tell them to go [ __ ] off
yeah android voice is at the door
i still just really want to do
just anybody ever hire me for one of
those marketing trailers where i get to
do the red dead two lady voice which is
like in red dead redemption 2.
i just want to do it so bad gameplay
one of our play watch listens where
you're like now troy is going to bring
up something unrelated and like
a director commentary i'll do a
director's commentary oh my hello as a
different person i know i know i've
never seen a dog knock and use their
[ __ ] at a doorbell by the way
so she's baby very protective which
means she will only lose her [ __ ] about
things that are in my immediate
proximity she won't leave to go not a
good long-term planner look at that
looking like your financial portfolio
and start barking
like a deer she's gorgeous she really is
yeah she's so pretty yeah i yeah i do
hope that i can adopt her i just just
want to make sure it wouldn't be mean
but yes basically anyone who's
immediately around me she cares very
much about she won't leave my side i
managed to get her to go outside to go
to the bathroom while i was inside
yesterday and she was just staring at me
the whole time she's like
i had i'll have to send you the picture
um i
i'm obviously out of town
pam was
pam and traveler were um i think they
were hanging out with travis and laura
they were hanging out travis lawrence so
she's like you know
not close to our house and all of a
sudden i see the ring notification that
there's motion or front door i was like
what so i look and i see nothing it's
like okay
and i see it again i was like what the
hell and i look and i see just this on
the bottom right hand corner just this
little blonde
moving back and forth and i zoomed in
and looked and 8-bit had somehow gotten
out
and after his escapades he was like okay
i'm ready to go back inside out and he
was just parked with his butt pressed up
against the front door like somebody
come let me in oh my god and he stayed i
stayed on the phone with him i was like
hey buddy i'm right here stay right by
the door that's cute yeah and he like
looked at the doorbell dad
and i called pam was like you need to
get home right now
and she
remember she said she's like travelers
naked i don't know what to do because
traveler just doesn't want to put
clothes on and just like leave them
there and she drove home that she got in
and he was so happy to see her dogs are
the best yeah they're pretty wonderful
um speaking of dogs just you know a
transition that works in my head for
some reason i'm very excited about that
kirby game
oh i didn't see it oh my god it's a
post-apocalyptic one right yes
what are you so excited about the kirby
game like i need to watch that trailer
i've always loved cubby
zombies
i mean you eat a car
you eat a traffic cone it is it's like
kirby but it's set in like a semi-photo
realistic post-apocalyptic world it's
yeah some of it looks like the last
night in the pitch meeting yeah and the
first exactly like the last of us
some of it legitimately looks like a lot
of us it's like a like a busted up mole
oh my gosh i just think it looks so like
i've always enjoyed kirby and like some
of the games aren't great some of them
are very good um but i feel like this
one just something about like the 3d
kirby ridiculousness of becoming a car
in a post-apocalyptic world as kirby i'm
so on board and that's the thing that i
love about nintendo directs is
i just feel like they
there's always something that you don't
expect there i know a lot of people are
really excited about um live alive which
uh i only know about because of pair
schneider who was um co-founder of ign
when i worked they would talk about it
all the time as a japanese-only
release that's now coming to the west
that that is super exciting i know a lot
of people are excited about advanced
wars
um there's always something for
everybody the thing i respect in
ourselves sorry because it is the it's
the mario hat mechanic right that
they've based but they've they're it's a
really nice reuse it's a really nice
reuse of it i just wanted may i point
out please i looked this game up and and
and under the def the description of it
it goes you know google will give you
people also ask
yeah all right
so i want to give you is troy baker in
destroy baker voice kirby
is kirby a boy or a girl number one
question interesting
um the others the other questions next
to that is what is kirby's real name
isn't it
kirby's original name
would later be referenced in curvy mass
attack as it is set on the po islands
huh that's cute yeah it's named after
they had um
uh an american lawyer literally white
i believe his name was yeah they raised
bent kirby
jesus i believe his name was steve
he
kirby
like a sort of round man and uh
kirby he was known for eating everything
yes just literally
ate the boardroom table during a meeting
sorry guys i was really hungry on my way
pan because wasn't um
wasn't jaws named after a lawyer as well
wasn't bruce the shark is what might be
right bruce jaws
and stephen
they're lloyd
bigger jaws
we're gonna distance myself
i will not be associated with that joke
going forward thank you great here we go
strike that from my record please
it was just trying to make his it was
either gonna be that or swedish he was
gonna be
yeah josenstein or whatever he'll be
like how dare you
um
but just i mean get back in the hot
water it's starting to yeah you've been
you're being canceled for a second time
and it's because you said bruce jaws
yeah who
i can't keep going
anyway i think that game looks awesome
the thing with mario kart that i find
interesting
um have you guys played a lot of mario
kart 8 bring it absolutely
i think it's the best i think it's
fantastic it's one i want the soundtrack
that soundtrack is a slaps
is the soundtrack not available anymore
i feel like nintendo famously is
horrible about this uh really they've
never they actually interesting they
they they yeah they never uh
they they i shouldn't say never but it's
it's pretty hard to get a hold of
of uh soundtrack albums to tons of like
original disney uh nintendo stuff
interestingly they are famously
pretty terrible in the content creation
space too um in that you know they used
to restrict people from even posting
let's plays but most recently took down
a whole bunch of channels that were
creating like pokemon fan content it's
the same with live
live shows like a friend of mine
developed the um that twilight of the
goddess zelda
orchestra tour
oh yeah and they
made it sound like from just a legal
standpoint that was an unbelievable
nightmare to get off the ground and it
really only worked they only i think if
i had to guess i'm not quoting them
directly here but i suspect part of the
only reason they were able to do that in
the end was because it was only that but
for example i've done a lot of shows
with video games live and they always
had very very little on there by way of
nintendo because those licenses were
incredibly tedious to get
yeah well i just can't find their
soundtrack albums on anything i'm having
a look you're absolutely right no yeah
and my friend a very good friend of mine
danny baranowski wrote the music for
cadence of hyrule
um
which they also
no soundtrack album was allowed to be
released which is surprising given that
his soundtrack to the predecessor to
that crypt of the necrodancer was like a
mega hit it was practically as
practically as popular as the game
itself
and interesting because i feel like
nintendo's music is always that way like
it's always very popular some of the
most i mean i would argue that
koji kondo's theme to the original mario
is the most iconic piece of video game
music ever written in the history of the
medium like
yeah that like the fact that have you
ever seen those like kids react to
nintendo where they'll hear the theme on
it boot up and they don't even know what
it is but they can finish the melody
that it goes
and they go blue and like they think
you can have never seen it and you know
what it is you know what it means kids
are like that with mario that theme
that's why i always say people hold up
that he wrote the theme to zelda and
mario and they treat those as equal
musical accomplishments and i've always
said mario is a thousand times more than
zelda and as a musical achievement
because not everyone on the planet knows
you know bum bum
but they do know mario
yeah also if i called my dad and i said
what is this and i hum to mario he'd
know what it was not just that was funny
also more original because the way i
look at it hold that thought troy i want
to know what's funny but here's my one
little my one little thought is
uh you have a japanese studio
i love it
hold it yeah
you mix you missed all the flexing
earlier a lot it's a theme of the
episode
do i have to watch it back well for your
director's commentary you have to regard
it
so you have a japanese composer writing
music about italian plumbers
crushing turtles and sort of
quasi-dinosaur bad guy dragon types and
the response to that is to write like
lounge jazz which well
i'm like it's the biggest acid trip of
originality in ever like everything
about that go i don't know why any of
those variables add up on the thing
but it adds up into a thing that is
eternal so yeah to me to me koji kondo
is uh that contribution just transcends
everything and the fact that the fact
that um they're they're they hold that
so close to the chest i think it's
probably just part of the sort of
corporate culture that's just part of
just the the the nature of how a lot of
japanese companies operate because it
seems to be not just nintendo that but
they're famously famously that way in in
the music domain okay troy let it go
i don't know if i would recognize as as
readily
like zelda especially
um if it had been presented in a
different form like if someone sat down
at the piano if there was like a violent
concerto that was playing that or
whatever i don't know if i would
recognize that as much as the
original 8-bit music of zelda you know
what i mean i mean well there are
orchestral like all the subsequent you
know you listen to like breath of the
wild you can hear an introspective piano
version or yeah
it just has this like i could recognize
the song of storms anywhere i think but
that i feel like it's because ocarina of
time is a music-based
game
[Music]
that's what one generation hears that
you know
my head went to simpsons yeah yeah but
but for me yeah
it's pretty i i hear them both but that
that's always one of those anytime i'm
screwing around in that mode i'll
accidentally bump up against that and i
go nope walk away uh
you're just gonna end up derivative
but it's such a good groove
but i feel like uh i feel like mario
kart like also has yeah incredible music
and uh what i was going to say was
actually sorry um i had friends who
did this pokemon rpg like d d thing that
i guessed it on for an episode
which was super fun and they had a whole
app that somebody had made around it
where it like tracks your stats
um so that you could play this like d d
version nintendo took it down um they
yeah they've taken youtube channels
recently uh i've heard of them even
taking down like people had just parties
that were pokemon themed like maybe it
was a bar that did it but nintendo shut
it down they're just very protective of
vip and i guess it works for them
because we still do
after all this time look at nintendo's
wholesome family content which is
exactly what they're going for and it
can't be easy to maintain that well this
is what i was saying about mario kart is
that the thing that i i love about the
game and the reason why i'm so into it
is it's just an easy pick up and and set
down game it's super challenging for me
the higher up you go
and but it's still something that
traveler can pick up and play as well
and we actually got the cart the
physical cart that has a camera on it
and using ar
it's
so
much fun is it i i i saw all the
trailers i never tried it i was always
skeptical it's so worth it it is it's so
kitschy and but it's so much fun you set
up a race and you you draw the by using
the cart you draw the race course around
your house
and
it does the whole thing like on mario
kart it sets up power-ups and it sets up
the the i did not know everything that
sounds awesome yeah it is so much fun
and if you get two of them together it's
hilarious
it looks like it's going so fast because
the camera is just like you know
whitening like a gopro and you play it
on your switch but it's like when around
it's going so slow
um i i have to bounce because transpo is
going to be picking me up into just a
little bit but uh before before i leave
um alana
can i um
can i buy you a power strip so you don't
have a fire hazard that's happening
behind you so
that is there
because usually
[ __ ] man
[Applause]
worthy
it's there because usually my dev kit is
there so all of those cables are like
neatly packaged around the dev kit but i
moved the dev kit upstairs just because
i wanted to lay in bed while playing but
that brick plugged into the plug with
like 20 uh
it has to be that way though you need
because it's also like that so that's my
my work cable but also the dev kit just
and the tv it requires so much and you
also like just that i can't really talk
about it probably but the set the setup
for the dev kits is complicated sure
because power strips just get a power
strip nice little power strip
it keeps it for some reason it doesn't
surge protector which is quite useful
which would save you a difficult i don't
have a surgery
okay all right that part is all right
back up
one two three four
all i know is that any moment your dog
is gonna go the floor is on fire
[Laughter]
and the chair
she won't care if we're in a different
room though if it's not nearby
it's fine i'm not worried about it um
but i was gonna ask before you do go
troy um not that i'm asking you i'm
really asking mike i guess you can leave
if you want all right mike
do you have a guest phone i just feel
bad about this
do you have a guess for why they um
like a business instinct guess for why
they haven't made mario kart 9 and
they're continuing to just release mario
kart 8 forever when nintendo was not
typically like a live games or service
company
maybe i think that's why they're testing
it because they are starting to push
more and more
mike yeah that's right all right i can
see the floor i'm magnanimous in my uh
please try to give us your other day
actually troy try to give mike's like
try to just embody mike's response and
give us now i want to hear your joy
as well please trust us
hello everybody oscar
my name is oscar what uh
hello oscar but you can give your actual
answer if you want to
look i i i buy a lot of stuff off of
switch and i i see that they're starting
to push more like hey you can you can
get this if you're part of the online
community and this is really starting to
push nintendo online and i think that if
you have such a big successful franchise
like mario kart that's a really good way
to go why don't we just start
transitioning everybody over to here and
you'll get you know in-game um uh
add-ons as opposed to you know add in
its add-on you get more carts you get
more courses
um i don't think they can add any more
characters
um and i don't think anybody really uses
their amiibos for that i mean i don't i
just
i go back and forth
traveler likes to play as windy it's the
funniest thing he thinks that she is
hilarious
because she's so grumpy
so he'll be like i'm windy i'm grumpy
um but yeah i i i think that's what it
is but uh to be honest with you i'm
really more interested to know uh what
mike mike thinks mike i'd love to hear
your answer yeah mike that's very kind
exactly what's about i knew he was gonna
leave i [ __ ] knew it i knew it it's
would be hilarious is like he lost power
and he's going no on the other hand
oh well i disrespect myself
exactly yeah his power broke yeah um
honestly i similar to what troy said i
think the thing that people the mistake
people always make with nintendo is they
think they're not
that they think they're not kind of
weird or bold or experimental in what
they do i think it's like you know when
you see that footage like that slow-mo
footage of like not slow-mo like um
time-lapse footage of plants where in if
you look at a plant it's moving but very
slowly and then when you speed it up
you're like oh that thing's like a
a thing that's alive that makes sense
nintendo's exactly the same it's a weird
metaphor i apologize how is nintendo
exactly the same as you don't want
timelines
they are they are one of the most
innovative
they're one of the most innovative
they're super innovative
but in a very kind of clever slow
methodical way so like there's that
thing that someone pointed out which is
utterly true which is that they
basically have successfully launched a
new ip once a year for like the last 10
years like in and with like clockwork
like they basically always bring out one
new ip you think of nintendo as
basically making mario and zelda games
on the loop but actually if you look
they are absolutely cultivating these
kind of
landmarks of trying to trying out new
ips sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't but generally kind of works
pretty steady so the answer to this
question for me is
the reason this isn't mario what would
it be mario kart 9 now right it would be
the next one the reason it's not that is
because it doesn't need to be yet
because they can absolutely take their
time
you're you you're asking for it as a
player but like they know full well that
they can put out some cool new tracks
they can put out some new characters
whatever and they'll keep that audience
going and also honestly they probably
are as troy said kind of wanting to
experiment with this stuff but with an
ip that they know people are already
into it's also mario kart as well by
nature of its design is very expandable
right it's very easy to add new tracks
and i'm excited about all the new tracks
like yeah it's super cool um and i think
it's yeah part of it when i saw people
complaining that they haven't brought
out a new one as someone who doesn't
care maybe i should have been more
reflective why don't i that game is
still so good and i still play it
frequently i'm sure a lot of people
still do um adding new content satisfies
my need for more mario kart as opposed
to creating an entirely new mario kart
because i don't feel like
what i don't even know what they can do
um and it seems better to maintain that
franchise with like back-to-back bangers
than to release something just because
they're not playing on a two-year loop
like everyone else they're planning like
five ten years ahead they're they're
they're looking at mario kart nine and
going there's no reason to do this
there's no there's no new hardware we
want it's probably like there's no
experiment that we want to do
yeah i mean that's probably why
the quote uh
of like no one remembers your release
date uh is always attributed to yamoto
anyway of uh
at least that i always see you know
there's probably multiple people that
have said similar things but the idea
that
the release date matters a lot less than
the thing you are releasing and take
your time
push a year push two years do what it
takes
you know and it seems like that that is
milton's their model yeah that yeah that
seems to be their thing because there
are very few games
like you mentioned you know these
these big tentpole
um
uh like ac or far cry or like they they
have a tendency to be like oh this is
the one that the audience really loved
next one didn't strike quite as much but
then the next one really did whereas you
know the lesser successful zelda titles
for example
are still
like
yeah like i think i think and and and
they they almost entirely have
just a plus
output in that one nintendo make such
good games like they do and so like
they're so polished and their file sizes
are so small
oh my god
my cables jesus
the file sizes that's the thing i don't
know how they do it like if everything's
that polished they have great music um
they're they're beautiful and they have
so few bugs
she pulled my whole dress to the table
yes because she needs to go to the
bathroom
um
yeah but they're all so tiny like i just
feel like they're so
efficient in a way that that we
unfortunately don't understand because
they're also incredibly secretive
they also have like they've built their
they use as far as i know the bulk of
their games it's not true of all of
their games with the bulk their games
are working on their own internal
engines which will be
free of a lot of the guff that those of
us in the rest of the games industry
have to kind of put up with yeah um
they're also targeting a lower
resolution which means that they're
targeting lower texture sizes which
means again that's a that's a big big
issue that is true uh stylistically
their games definitely uh towards that
but yeah it's great and they they put
the work in it's the book i recommended
earlier the um have you read that alana
oscar water
yeah i loved it
yeah it kind of sums up a lot of this
thought process it's ashamed beautiful
because you have really good no i i feel
shamed because you instantly knew what
he was saying
that was the joke troy was doing was
they were like they just didn't get it
we
both and i had no idea what he was
saying it was like one of these weird
moments of oh you would say ask iwata
yes that's how you talk like that hi i'm
austin winnery and i'm reading ask iwata
that's it's on caddy it's like there's
two
i try not to do it too often because it
makes people think that i'm austin and
it seems like that should be yeah you
don't want to you don't want to like
diminish
it it gets you in certain rooms like
with imagine dragons this is messing my
brain up
it is funny though when you go in when i
like um so because kerry's kerry's
working in america at the moment but
she's in portland
and so i'm going over to portland every
now and again and people don't
understand my accent there like it's
really weird thing like it's something
i've not really positioned a privilege
i've never experienced before like
because when you go to like like a
metropolis well portland's metropolitan
but you know i mean like when you go to
like a big tourist city
portland
i mean portland is
footprint than literal size like it it's
it is actually a pretty it's lovely it's
lovely but it's definitely like a
smaller end but
i think when i was in australia i
probably wouldn't have known what
portland was i probably won't since
coming here i probably wouldn't have
heard of the city it no it makes sense
so one thing that i was saying this is
someone the other day that i've heard
brits say that nobody understands is the
way some brits pronounce the word salt
americans would say salt
some brits say salt
s-a-w-e salt
they don't put the l or the t they just
say salt and that doesn't translate very
well i definitely
when i'm talking to americans i
definitely like posh myself up a little
bit like definitely go a little bit uh a
little colin firth no that's okay
oh my gosh yeah
you're right
that that's been a funny uh subjective
conversation with angela where she moved
here
and
we'll be watching something and like
it'll be some joke where somebody has
like a really really exaggerated new
york accent or whatever
and i'll i'll all laugh and she'll go
why did you laugh because it that the
subtext of that just as someone who
didn't grow up in the united states and
who watched a lot of
american media with over like they they
it's standard in
in latin america to just watch the latin
american dub as opposed to
the uh the original english like if it's
a tv show or a movie or something from
the us so she um
so i would say like i would say you know
but
so the concept of why something could be
built to
play off those is is
totally normal to her but what's
hilarious to me is that in my mind like
a strong new york accent or a boston
accent versus like a texas accent or a
deep south like alabama georgia
mississippi exit troy be having so much
fun right now
we're missing out we're missing out the
differences between those are so blaring
and she just hears and goes it just
sounds like an american and it's like
they all meld together for her yeah they
have to be so extreme and i remember
thinking
wow i just can't calibrate to that but
then again she'll listen to you know 15
spanish speakers and be like argentinian
nicaraguan and i have the same problem
and i'm like
damn it's so interesting isn't it how
you just can't you can't force your way
through i still can't tell the
difference between an american accent
and a canadian accent
really
no no i've gotten in trouble for that
several times yeah they don't like it
when you but i could tell you if i could
tell you where a brit was from but i
tell you where in australia it's from
yeah like most of the things
that at least five not all canadians
have brilliant you can literally do like
though 20 miles yeah like some canadians
have pretty much neutral
yeah we had to do something we've been
around so long we had to find something
to do with
inventing accents
you know the language
it was like that or invade other
countries without permission at least
you piped down
you're okay
um in any case i feel like i need to
take this dog for a walk before my next
meeting before she destroys myself
which is very good though because first
couple of days she was just [ __ ]
inside she now
tries very hard to occupy herself until
i can take her out so that's the reason
that's the plus
i know she's i'm surprised to say when i
move somewhere new it's fine [ __ ] in the
house or just break stuff i get it
classic white pickle
she's so receptive to positive and
negative feedback that she's really easy
to train like how old that's good she's
full
wow that's even more surprising yep very
easy to train but she has a uh basically
an eating disorder so she can't eat
anything other than her exact prescribed
food so you can't train her with treats
you can only train her with positive
reinforcement you know what my dog loves
we give her as a treat she gets so
excited and it's just the cheapest date
ever she loves ice
uh and
and so yeah you're allowed to have ice i
could try that that's the thing like
it's somehow
seen as uh so like it we make smoothies
a fair amount so i go to the ice
dispenser with just excited
she freaks out so it has to she it's
like we have to give her ice when we
make smoothie but as a result she loves
it when we when we do it and it's the
it's the easiest it's the easiest treat
ever uh
we have the same but sometimes yeah
sometimes the slightest thing i'm like
you're such a you're such a delicate
little flower that like a microscopic
alteration to your diet and and we have
hail to pay for it she will die is the
issue well she has yeah if she has
anything that isn't her prescribed food
it will kill her um which is very
stressful when you go on a walk
and she gets something in her mouth
thankfully she's not aggressive so i can
just take it out of her mouth and she
won't do anything about it but anytime
she picks something up i'm like no
you'll die please no she wouldn't die
immediately it would take a bit like
it's just not a good time um i gotta
take it for a walk all right thank you
everybody for watching this play watch
listen
troy baker was here
uh that's austin wintry he's a video
game composer that's mike bethel it's
not it doesn't work when you record it
either austin because it's not my
perspective pretty sure you're pointing
at my dog saying that's right i just
look like a dummy that's mike bithell
that's fair that's fair
uh poops in the house all plays with
stuff
that's amazing noted you just get
stressed in a new place you know do you
sorry wait a minute do you not poop for
the
[Laughter]
i feel like we've discovered something
fascinating
poop
uh
we are going to be at dice next week so
we're going to figure out for the
listeners if we can record something in
the same room
which would be very cool but we can't
guarantee it because it's kind of
complicated to set up so we'll see if we
can it would be very cool if we can
we've got the pug plugs for haven't you
so we're we're halfway hey i'm [ __ ]
set back here i'll just bring that whole
brick
you'll regret making fun of me
uh we'll see you next week everyone